hey guys and welcome back to the layah heilpern
show powered by icon plus since it's powered
by iconplus i have a news announcement
for you so more than 60 of ics tokens
are locked up by investors which means that
more people are investing long term in icon
and actually earning up to 12 interest per
year passive income so this is also powered by
and sponsored by blockfi so i want to give
a quick shout out to them and say thank you
um because i actually use them to earn up to 8.6
interest on my uscc usdc is a stable coin so you
can earn so much interest when you're in crypto
so i'm going to leave the link in the description
in the bio wherever you want to get it and you
can earn i think actually at the moment it's
around 250 if you deposit with them and before we
start the show a last final shout out to coinflip
so coinflip are doing some incredible work across
the states they're pushing bitcoin mass adoption
they have um a bunch of atms i think it's nearly
over 800 atms in 45 different states so huge shout
out to them they're doing some amazing work so
joining me today is somebody a little different
i'm really excited to chat to him it's going
to be super unfiltered um i actually have no
specific questions lined up it's just gonna be
um we're just gonna go for it okay so um so he
is a boxer entrepreneur competitive chess player
and he focuses on self-improvement it is of course
ed latimore how are you doing i'm doing
fantastic you know i heard you going through
all the sponsors and i said you know what i'm a
fish out of water because i don't know anything
about crypto and i should and i'm sure that's
like that's like admitting you don't believe in
god in the church like me saying that right yeah
sure but uh but but eventually uh i'm sure i will
learn about it because it seems like the kind of
thing where if you don't learn about it you're at
a marked disadvantage moving forward in the future
100 i actually wasn't even gonna bring crypto up
but since we're here i wasn't gonna do it but but
since we're here you are somebody who's all about
you know you're an entrepreneur you're all about
sort of like doing a best pushing forward and
pushing through the pain you know forgetting
the emotion just keep going i feel like
and also you're all about taking personal
responsibility i feel like that's totally in line
with crypto and particularly with bitcoin like do
you have any interest whatsoever well you you know
so all of that yes all of that is perfectly in
line with the philosophy and i've actually read uh
what is that that book the bitcoin standard i
thought it was a great great book um if for any
other reason it made me understand exactly what
money is and how money works i said okay that's a
really cool idea uh as far as my personal interest
and it goes right now it seems like a thing
to invest in like a commodity um what i what i
was interested in initially was like okay is this
going to be a thing that eventually in my lifetime
replaces fiat currency and if it does then what
are the implications of that for a regular person
because you have to remember uh i i think i'm very
i think i'm blessed in the perspective that i
get grown because i grew up uh extraordinarily
poor as poor as you can really be in america and
not be homeless i was in public housing i believe
you guys call those commonwealth estates over in
the uk i grew up in the car's car council stages
yeah i grew up in in that environment and then
you know i had a brief step with the middle class
and i think i think there's no real definitely
not middle class anymore i don't know if i'm
i'm officially like upper class but definitely
not there but what that what that does is having
that going through that path of life is you have
perspective and my perspective is okay like how
does the normal person make use of this and if
i can't if i can't get to how a regular person
who wakes up at like you know 10 at night and
wants to go get some 40s down the block like
if i can't figure out how they're gonna use it
uh to do so then then i'm not there you know
which which like one of the things to change
my mind is a whole only fans thing for example
my first thought was like okay guys that want
to go to the strip club how they gonna drop you
know make it rain with bitcoin and then
they're gonna make it rain with bitcoin
all of a sudden you have this this influx
of it's the best way to put this digital
yes digital voyeurism and there's a lot of there
are a lot of different ways to pay pay for your
pleasure now and and all those can be those
transactions can be conducted in a digital manner
so i think as the world moves more digital uh it
it starts making more sense to me how the common
person gets involved with it and i think the
ultimate dream uh if i'm not mistaken of many
people who are in the space uh what we realize
which is that it replaces uh fiat non-bad currency
uh but but right now my mind can't get there and
then you know what does that have to do with my
interest in it uh right now because i'm so focused
on uh generating a certain amount of income my
mind just does not let me go invest in some things
now that is definitely changing uh probably in
2021 but uh that i'm just explaining my past and
why i've not converted uh to the church of bitcoin
yeah okay so you so much gone on there so firstly
i think that's really interesting you make such
an interesting point about you know sex work is
now online i'm actually not a huge fan of that
industry but um as a woman i would say i think
it's an incredible option because it's safer
and you know people can pay in bitcoin and bitcoin
at the moment is on the absolute run so you know
speaking of coming from such a poor background
if somebody gave you like 50 let's just say um
i don't know whether like a few months ago you
would have absolutely you know made a lot of
money on it by now and you'll continue to um but
i wanted to talk about you mainly don't talk too
much about bitcoin but i think that's super cool
no but it's cool it's cool it's cool that you have
an interest in it but i want to talk about you
because you are a lot of different things you're
a boxer author competitive chess player so it's
insanely diverse so how would you define yourself
uh i am someone who who i i heard this phrase i
don't know if you're familiar with a hotep jesus
but i heard that phrase he he used it on donovan's
sharp show he's i'm a guy who realized that his
life didn't match his ambition and so one day i
woke up and i said okay how do i how do i start
making how i see myself become reflected in
reality so other people see me that same way
and i said okay let me let me go and do the things
that challenge me and push me that other people
won't do can't do and see how far i can go
you know i my motto like i always tell people
when they go are you afraid about afraid of
getting hurt in the ring or dawn or whatever and
i'm gonna die anyway right let me get some stories
out of this life at least you know at least when
i'm old someone's not like oh goodness here comes
grandpa getting like not like okay man here comes
this guy he's got something cool to talk about
and and that mentality you know perhaps is not the
physically safest but it has led to a very
interesting life because i didn't start
boxing when i was younger like i made a conscious
decision as an adult to go i'm going to go do this
and not only am i gonna go do it uh at a high
enough level you know if i can get there but i
wanna i'm gonna do it the right way which is start
as an amateur no one's paying you no one cares
most of your fights you know a lot of them get
cancer you waste all evening and stuff like that
but but it pushes you and you developed uh you
develop a a certain kind of grit that you can't
get anywhere else and it also and i talk about
this a lot one of the best things boxing did for
me is it shifted my mindset from fix to growth i
had a fixed mindset about about a lot of things
academically and and i said wait a second if i
can learn how to fight man because i was not very
good when i started and and i did not think i
thought i was going to become good i'm sure a
lot of people around me didn't think much would
develop of me but i kept learning the diligent
approach whatever and when i when i seen what that
did for my amateur career and in my professional
career i said okay you know if i did it there
can i do the same thing for my mind can i can
i make myself uh intelligent can i approach
problems that i had probably because i had a
big issue with math i wrote about it on my site
uh a few different articles and i said no we're
gonna we're gonna do this like boxing because it
can't be worse than boxing because this is a real
like negative feedback mechanism when you make a
mistake worst thing that happens i get the wrong
answer in a math problem right so i took
that approach and and it helped me become
who i am today and get through those things to
get my physics degree to go on and now learn chess
and writing the whole idea to sum me up is is i
believe that if i have if i'm given enough time
i can learn anything and i'm going to choose
things that are going to force me to develop
and that's really what my life is about i try to
continue to develop myself and continue to improve
and i know i'll never max out i'm gonna die
before them but that's no reason to not try right
yeah i think there's so much going
on here so i want to kind of go back
to you know because you said you did grow up in
a council estate it was very very poor um you
know you were very poor school was very difficult
and there wasn't a lot going on essentially um i
think i read on your site you said you that you
had a lot of anger issues so you've clearly gone
from i mean at the beginning you sort of said
my upper class now you know so you've gone from
you've done like three classes you know if
that's even possible so my question to you
then is you know what is going on right now
because if we look at today's world we have
there's a lot of issues in terms of culture wars
class wars um you know people sort of the idea
of personal responsibility is sort of frowned
upon um you know people sort of are unable to
you know do anything great for themselves because
they have a million reasons why they can't so
coming from such a background that you came from
why do you think you were able to but other people
aren't able to and also actually ask the next bit
after go for it and also then i will ask it now
i i remember i was i was reading and you said you
know your father wasn't always super present so
even you had that against you as a young man so
how how does that go why why were you able to
and other people can't um uh aside from luck right
because that's a useless i don't believe in life
um you know i i i remember that i never wanted
to feel weak and i figured out very early that
there are a few ways to feel weak and i i tried to
avoid all of one is when when people had control
over how you felt they can make you feel a certain
way they can make you angry they can make you cry
whatever right they can make you divert your uh
path i remember one time i was afraid of this
bullying on my bus so i started walking to
school now remember i'm i'm like i mean like
like probably i remember where i
lived so i was probably like seven
and i'm walking like over two two miles to school
whatever and that's uh that's hard that's a thing
that you don't ever want like you don't want to
experience that type of weakness so so you learn
you start you start experimenting with ways to
not experience that and and one of the biggest
ways is to to always be in control yourself when
you're always in control yourself what happens
is you you start having a certain expectation
heaped upon you and either you rise to meet that
or you you get punished and you lose you know
freedoms abilities um access to things that can
they can make your time pass better okay so here
it all starts with the emotional control and not
being responsive to my environment creating my own
kind of inner peace in my own world because that
mean i had to there was there was nothing around
me that suggested uh safety or security or peace
i had to create those environments up here and in
doing so i went all right why can't i can do this
what else helps me do that okay doing the opposite
of everyone around me and it just not just so
happens i mean i had to do it because i didn't
want to be part of that environment because i
was trying to create a space different than what
was around me that meant showing up on time for
example like i actually i mean i'm still to this
day a stickler about time like really cats down
people are late or my my girlfriend jokes that
like we get to the airport two hours early all the
time it's not really jumping i guess we do because
i'm i'm so terrified of like being late but
you get it right so so i try to be
in control of my time uh i try to
if i see a difficulty i don't ever want that
difficulty to sneak up on me because one of the
things you just learned that if you face it head
on you might not get an advantage but you aren't
at a disadvantage at least not as big at least
not a bigger one than if you try to escape it
and you have to deal with it eventually so how
i developed this mindset again i have to face
this problem before this problem decides to face
me because if it fazes me uh and i'm not ready
we got a big problem or i like to say you know you
can pay now or you can pay later if you paid now
you might get a discount if you pay later you're
definitely going to have to kick it with interest
so you pick which one is up you know which one
you want to do so having that mentality right
so now i got control of my time now and then i'm
trying to create my environment and in doing so
i have to face any problem that comes up and the
ability to do that to recognize what a problem is
is is i i never got a chance to deceive myself
i never got a chance to believe that someone
was my friend if they weren't because that was
a costly mistake i never got a chance to believe
that something would turn out okay just because i
hoped it did i always went and made sure uh things
will work the way i wanted them to i never got
comfortable letting things be out of my control
and so if if i'm able to do those four things and
this is really the first time i've ever kind of
broken that down maybe i'll like turn it into an
article or something but if i'm able to do those
four things if i'm able to control my emotions
and then control my environment face problems as
they're coming at me and i can face them because
i do not let myself become deceived by reality
and this and remember this isn't like me as a kid
going this is my master plan for ruling the world
now this is just so i can cope with the day-to-day
like like either at school or at home you get
those you know i got those four things done and so
so i don't i don't understand how one is able to
live not in control not wanting to be in control
looking for anything to blame looking for things
to be outraged about like all of those things
go against everything that has helped me survive
and continues to help me thrive you know i think
that's fascinating um you know you say these are
the things that helped you survive um i just
for me you know i i totally agree with you
anyway which is obviously you know one of the main
reasons why you know i saw you online and i was
like oh wow i really agree with everything this
guy is saying i think it's such a shame um that
people are unable to adopt these kind of
mentalities or don't agree with these mentalities
um because you know i know you agree anyway
but no one's coming to save you right so i
think it's such a shame that we can't sort of
agree that no one's coming to save us because
even the government you know even if they
let's say they really did have our best
intentions at heart they literally just can't
there's too many people you know what i mean
and even if they did come and save you they
it would the only way that money really could
stretch is to bring everybody down to the
lowest common denominator which is communism
but communism aside you know oh man you're
spitting right now you're saying something okay
one of the things i was just talking about this
with my buddy uh yesterday and it always i i
came to this conclusion maybe last year that there
aren't really two political parties wow i know you
guys are in the uk you are in europe you have
a bit of a different system no we're the same
two parties right but there there's uh
there's not really two political parties
it's not really conservative liberal nothing
what it is is it's people who believe
that something is going to save or protect
them whether that be the government whether
that be a god whatever okay and it's people
who understand that no one is coming to save
them and they've got to figure this thing out
on their own and if you look at it that way
it's not entirely accurate but it's useful enough
and precise enough to where you can make accurate
predictions and useful predictions for example
i should not be able to but we can i should not
be able to look at your stance on the coronavirus
and tell where you lean politically but i can and
the reason for that is there tends to be a strong
enough overlap remember the model is not perfect
but it's useful enough to where we can make useful
uh or we can make some predictions that allow us
to determine the best kind of course of action to
go i can look at how you feel about one thing and
guess how you feel about a bunch of other things
because of that model if you think the government
is coming to save you you probably support all
kinds of things where i just go ah i can't really
get behind it i mean like good for you but
i can kind of see where this is going to go
and you know a great example of this is one of
the arguments that we have here in the united
states is the 15 minimum wage okay and and and
on one side it's like oh great everyone has more
money me on the other hand because i could never
i never let myself get deceived by reality so one
of the things that i studied it was economics just
being curious and i'm like okay so if we if we do
this then what about all the people who make 14
an hour who were skilled and also what happens
when that's the new minimum wage and everyone just
raises the prices and now we've just got inflation
and yeah it's like you want to start a business
and you can't afford to pay someone 15 an hour
then it's just like that completely ostracizes
the people that they're trying to help you know
like people like yourself who came from those
kind of backgrounds well sorry you're just not
worth fifteen dollars right it's hilarious and
and you know to that because then what happens
a lot of times when you when you try to think
like this you often come up with ideas that are
counter-intuitive and perhaps not entirely popular
and one day i was just sitting around thinking
about it and maybe i was trying to troll maybe
i wasn't but i was thinking and i said you know
really the best thing to do in this like if you're
really worried about people being paid a great
wage the best thing to do would be to get rid of
the minimum wage entirely and let and let and let
competition sorted out and people were like what
i just kept thinking about it maybe and i don't
know if that is the most correct answer i'm just
riffing here to make an example of the the two
different thought processes but uh some people
will go that's great because i have the skill
to take care of myself and i'll figure it out
and on the other side people go that's horrible
we need regulations and plays we need someone to
take care of and protect us now you can't go you
know completely extreme or one extreme you get
anarchism anarchy and the other extreme you get
communism but like you know people who tend to
lean a little closer to anarchy probably tend
to think more like me and people who tend to lean
a little more towards communism but they'll never
say that uh tend to think not like me yeah i think
but also i think what we tend to forget when we
talk about minimum wage is that minimum wage was
never supposed to be living wage you know it was
never supposed to be something which um you know
will allow you to rent and pay your bills and
a little cushion you know so that you can afford
potentially to um buy a really cheap suit after
you've been working at this place for so long
and then you can afford to um you know put that
nice suit on to go to another interview and
work your way up like it was just supposed to
be like a little like it was never supposed
to be something which could pay your bills
um and actually you make a really good point
about the model of personal responsibility
so this is hilarious i don't know you may have
heard this i'm not sure but i think it was a uk
article they basically made um a headline the
headline was something like if you're a gym bro
if like you're one of those guys that you know
gym and all this stuff um you're more likely to
be a radical right-wing person because you take
personal responsibility for your health and the
way you look physically you know you don't have to
stop for movement which basically says it's okay
to be fat it's okay to be unhealthy um you know
they've taken personal responsibility so that
makes them more likely to be right-wing it's the
same thing here you know the joke is i can tell
i can tell which side of the line you're
on by the strength of your headshake
i don't know if one would say fortunately or
unfortunately but there is a lot more truth in
that than i think either sod wants there
to be but at the end of the day you know
i i think people people think that uh i'm i like
lead and right or whatever i have no idea what i
lean because i don't pay attention to politics
i know that i'm for personal responsibility
and it seems like uh that is a model or a um our
policy of of one side of one take and that is
you know coincidence at best uh you know at worst
you know probably someone actively trying to uh
keep one group of people or many groups of people
dependent on the government and those who don't
think that way or are radicals black sheeps
uncle toms whatever you want to call it
yeah i think it's a shame because i because
i think i actually think you know this kind
of mentality is the only way to succeed if you
continue um to sort of take a victim mindset
if you continue to sort of say i can't and i
i'm i'm you know the world is against me and i
need to vote this way i need to listen i need to
make democrats so that they can save me and all
this stuff you'll never get out of it it's sort
of like a continuation um i just feel like this
kind of mentality perpetuates it um but i want to
talk a little bit actually um about masculinity in
today's world um because you you mentioned that
you know your father wasn't really present and
that was a lot that was you had a lot of abuse
growing up and all these all these different
things so what are your thoughts on masculinity
today um from my perspective i see there's a huge
um i feel like there's a huge feminization
of men um you know that was the recent um
picture of harry styles and a dress and
all these things and i will say each other
each to their own whatever you want to do but i
just wanted to get your opinion on it um what what
is going on yeah you know it's cool you know it's
cool because like uh i can tell if you're bringing
this up you know you're probably you you're
probably on my side or you're setting a trap uh
don't think you said the trap so it's all things
are good um no but in all seriousness i i think
okay so sexual dimorphism is is a thing like
you don't look like me and i don't look like you
and that is a that's just a feature of the
species right you know we're not gonna dive
into the benefits pros cons of it that's just
uh what we are and each of us because of that
because of the dimorphism we come with certain
strengths and certain weaknesses each of us
it's it's a great error to group all the the the
okay so so what happens with the toxic masculinity
movement oh is that they throw the baby out with
the bath water they take traits that are masculine
and they're just bad okay not not the same thing
can be happening but it happens you know like
yeah stuff like that yeah but but but like 12 no
no no the same thing happens with women you know
but to a lesser extent almost to a non-existent
extent because like now you know it's been it's
effectively a crime really to criticize uh
women publicly but what what happened you know
what happens with a lot of the masculine traits is
you know they're they're immoral they're neither
good nor bad it's just you know who who wields
them you know is your is your villain uh the only
difference between a villain and a good villain
and a good hero is is one well his perspective or
the perspective of the people against and and how
he decides to use it you know uh the strength is
strength whether it's used to build or destroy
uh uplift or control uh dominate or dedicate
you know it's all strengthened it is a masculine
virtue a dedication intensity all of these things
here's the problem okay now that we've kind of
loosely defined what what masculinity is this
kind of active force in the world that's amoral
but makes things happen okay uh here's the problem
when when it starts when you're younger okay it
starts with boys being being a i think it was like
five i did a presentation on this uh two years
ago or a year ago i think and i think it was about
five times more likely to be diagnosed with
adhd now now if it was then now why is that
it's not like it's not that boys are are
you know have problems focusing it's that
we we have a world a structure for young for young
boys where they're told sit still in the classroom
for freaking almost eight hours a day and
there's something wrong with you if you can't
and that's problematic we have deregulated
uh a deregulated unregulated sexual market
we actually have a little little worse than
that if you can like an unregulated market is
a black market right in a black market uh if you
cross somebody they can come and cross you back
and that's what a black market is pretty much
operating outside the law and the criminals you
know keep things in check we call this
prison justice right as street justice
well it's a bit worse than that because if if if
a woman accuses you of something false for example
there's no recourse if she's caught really at
least not nearly as serious of a want to deter it
um there is no recourse you know if you decide
you don't want the kid but she does you still
have to pay right uh dave chappelle made
a great great joke about that he goes you
know your body your choice my wallet mantra you
keep but i decide i want to pay for them right
and then that's like where that is a reasonable
reaction a regional status but that's not there uh
why do i bring that up not just to go you know [
__ ] on the movement but to highlight that we've
we've now incentivized and forget disincentivizing
with shame right there because as we used to
have we used to disincentivize single moms
where there was no male in our household
and raised we used to just disincentivize um the
rampant sexuality we used to disincentivize that
no more shame shame died and then maybe when
i was in high school now we've incentivized
it we've incentivized it because there's a
government state that will make sure you're okay
like no matter what you won't be okay because
we're gonna give you some money if you have this
kid and not only that we're gonna we're gonna find
that we're gonna legally attack the the father the
kid you know now he should be responsible but my
point here is that the word though the weight of
responsibility is not equal it's gone and
you know so so how does this all relate to to
god's you know kind of the wall masculinity
whatever is not only are we told it's bad
from the from our development you know standpoint
but we're also not getting good examples
of it at home because many more kids are
being raised without fathers in their life
than they are right so that's happening the
school is insulting you on your on you being a boy
uh by virtue of the girl's position very often
she's more likely to be believed i mean that
there are so many there are many many stories of
that all she had all it takes is one accusation
as opposed to due process before someone's life
for for a god's life is ripped to absolute shreds
and that is problematic it's highly problematic
so you've got these these things in place and yet
i i am a firm believer uh that there's there's an
attack on on what it takes to be a man and that's
just one aspect of another aspect is the world is
very easy now and one of the things that kind of
shaped what made you a man was overcoming hardship
there are no hardships to overcome and we we are
basically wally the only the only difference
between here uh between this between 2020
and wally is in wally they figured out space so
they're in space they get technology but it's
the same thing you know you you can sit in your
house i remember even 10 years ago when i was 25
you know um if i'm only if i only made
800 a month man i had a rough life 800
a month now that's a netflix subscription
that's some cheap food it can be brought
to you and walked to you know cheap liquor um an
only fan subscription or all the porn in the world
so in case i don't you know which completely
demotivates you know we're not even gonna get
started on the poor thing but that's another force
that just completely because they trap you they're
like drug addicts it's like okay here's this
here's here's some breasts come on in check it out
you don't have to put in the work you don't have
to put in the work you don't have to do anything
it's it's all just it's all just there for you
yeah that's insane that's insane to think that
actually 800 would get you so much because you
know we think about like inflation though but
we think about inflation and like eight hundred
dollars was obviously worth more ten years ago
but maybe a thousand works no no but i'm
with you no but i'm with you because we
didn't you didn't have all of this ten
years ago so um yeah i'm talking with you
it's crazy because me humans in general
i think need a thing to push against but
within that subspecies men more men need
things to push against they need things to
challenge them they need to be able when they're
younger they're not being told that wanting to
to run around and play sports and have
a lot of energy is a bad thing they need
role models all these things are gone and
yeah i think ease is in place of it and so
it's gonna become harder and harder for for
guys to develop into men a good friend of mine
told me he's got a bunch of kids he said he's more
worried about his daughters being able to find a
decent guy to be with and his son being able to
find a woman because there because nothing has
in terms of the environment that is that is ideal
for for producing a woman so there are some things
that are like not good like you know the the
financial incentive of only fans and the porno
sites uh that's certainly no good but there's not
anything that actively impedes their development
just distractions along the path that with a good
home life are largely avoidable like a good family
not so much for god's god god needs to be
needs to get his ass kicked for example now
we got anti-bullying i'm not saying we need
bullies in schools but i'm saying you know
guys still a conflict differently we can fight
and then be friends and but you gotta fight first
but there are many more examples for strong
women in society they're all for men i gave
a speech at a program and and the woman came to
me she said you know the the if you can would
love for you to talk to somebody god specifically
because the girls get tons of attention this is a
woman i think she was in our late 50s early
60s uh so so from another era and notice
says that the gods are not getting the attention
and the the effort energy and and i know i i
i 100 feel it man because i i didn't have any
of that i think that's why uh i was interested
in football and then once football was gone in
high school i kind of floated around wayward and
then i didn't book but but something said you got
to find a thing to put some sweat equity in and
i found boxing and which in which these
are hard environments that shape you
and force you to be disciplined and accountable
and you have the channel your energy and
channel your aggression all the things that
society does not have an outlet for you to do
for god to do you can do it in boxing and it's
great like we have so many different ways and
outlets scholarships for and everything
um many different ways that are forming to
doesn't have to be success now it's a zero-sum
game so the more one side gets a thing the less
the other side gets and when we did that
and we've done this for a long time we as
humans have to come up with a better way
because it used to be the other way right
uh where it was where god's gotta there there was
much more in for society out there for god's but
not so much for for women if they wanted to
venture out but you know that gets into to another
argument but the the tldr to to kind of put a
cap on this this uh this part of the conversation
is that is it it is it is very hard for a boy to
develop into a man today and it's only going to
get harder the easier society gets and and part of
becoming easy almost by definition and i mean this
is easy isn't not facing resistance for anyone
who wants to make a joke but part of becoming
uh a man is the is that life is gonna come easier
and a feminized or women seek a path kind of less
resistance certainly physically and into a lesser
extent emotionally and guys don't get that option
but they but they but it doesn't come from nowhere
you got to develop it society's making it hard to
develop yeah that was a lot there um i want to
okay no it's good it's good it's good um so two
things i want to mention the first just back to
what you initially said um i'm absolutely with you
i think there's a lot of i think the government
has disincentivized um not just men and but just
people in general um to sort of like doing the
the thing which creates the better outcome right
so if it's sort of like um if it's like you know a
family unit kids and all this stuff like you said
they'll pay for you they'll pick they'll reward
you with money when you have let's say children
outside of a marriage and this and that and you
don't want to be responsible for it so that like
you said they will pay you and support you so it
disincentivizes you from wanting to do what could
create a better outcome long term but it is um
actually international men's wednesday yeah so
congrats happy international wednesday okay yeah
so i i was at conception and here i am here you
are i don't no no no no listen i'm the fact that
you didn't know basically just proves everything
you said right because you would know if it was
international women's day oh yeah yeah exactly
it's a great point i i and and if i wanted to i'd
have to block the hashtag but i know at that point
but i wouldn't block it i mean i've got i've got
nothing against my word at all no of course not
but what i want to what i want to say actually
is because you spoke a lot about boxing and how
you know it's sort of necessary needs that sort
of physical um that physical challenge in order
to become a man he needs all these challenges
you know spoke about adhd and all this stuff
um but from a female perspective i think of
course it's different you were saying you know
men need that to become a woman sorry to become
a man women don't need that to become a woman
but what i would say in terms of building
strong people regardless of gender um from
just my experience i think the best thing that men
like yourself who are into self-improvement and
you know challenging yourself physically can offer
women is encouraging them to do physical challenge
right so i saw um i saw a video earlier today
of a dad helping his his little girl in the gym
and i was like that is perfect i was like that
this is it this is what women need this is how
men can benefit women this is how they add value
to women because they're you know we all we both
add value to each other um whether it's you know
whether it's you know we help men when it comes
to sort of bringing out their more emotional side
or nurturing or whatever it is love and all this
stuff and care which is totally f we're happy to
i'm happy to do that that's you know what it is
and i think from my experience you know my brother
for example was a huge role model for me and he's
the one that got me in the gym and he's the
one that will turn around to me and say oh
my god leia of course you can do that you can
do anything and then i'm like oh yeah of course
they can do anything you know and that that
kind of rational that kind of like unemotional
hard opinion sort of it comes mainly
from men that sort of unemotional like
yeah you could do it like you know and i think
women need that and i think that's that kind
of strength that men have is what adds a lot of
value to women and i kind of wanted to highlight
that on international women's day because that's
sort of wednesday sorry because that's my that's
that's the thing that i find just to be the most
amazing thing about men in general for me they add
so much value in terms of making me feel powerful
and like i can i appreciate that and what you said
is so key and i wish everyone understood it we
need each other we we were not one of the things
about a sexual dimorphism when we're so different
is that to be whole we need one another one of
the things uh i i say i i made a point is that you
know when when two things are equal by definition
you don't need one of them but when they're
complementary you do and we complement one
another so well we you you're strong we're
weak and we're weak where you're strong
and together a society is built my fear my worry
and this is where the world is going uh is that
the the strengths are muted and the weaknesses
don't necessarily rise because you're not designed
to rise like like no matter how much you put
in the gym uh you ain't never gonna be as big
as me like ain't never gonna happen and
likewise uh i i don't and i'm pretty pretty damn
good with people i would never want to talk as
much as a typical woman and make that connection
i'm never going to feel good that way that
lately and that's important people need to
be comforted people need to become we need
strength to protect said comforting ability
but when you mute the differences you take
away the most beautiful part of each of us
and you make us when we're more weaker and
that's what i think happens because because um
gaps don't don't stay empty for long
if you if the less masculine you make
men the the more you punish their masculinity the
more you're forcing a woman to become masculine
and neither people are comfortable in the road
or both weaker you're not you don't get the
focus on being you and i don't get to focus on
being me and so now we're just kind of a mess
floating around neither one of us is really
good i forget jack of all trades master
kind of bad at everything now and that is
that is the biggest kind of danger i think
so so i really appreciate that that
notice of the role of encouraging
and supporting kind of no nonsense objective you
can do this attitude as opposed to because i mean
because it was you and you recognized like like
a girlfriend would be like oh you know like like
you may not get as much practical advice on
how to do it but you'll get a cheerleader
yeah exactly you need somebody that's like
you got this no matter what you're amazing
you're wonderful you go girl like you need that
but you also need someone to be like look here
we got this this and this and you can't you
can't face that right now but if we go here
and maybe get in the gym like six months you
can be eye to face this one and when you get
that one you'll be ready for that one like they're
they're true so much they're great i provide them
one isn't better than the other they they're
just they but they when you have both you become
unstoppable i mean you have neither which
is kind of where we're trending you can do
nothing yeah absolutely um totally with you you
need both you're right you need that you go girl
you got this you're beautiful you you know you
got this and then you need the okay stop crying
this isn't going to help you know you need that
you do but i think i think it's interesting though
particularly like the the whole feminism movement
and everything because it's sort of what the most
weird the most confusing part to me is that it
sort of encourages women to um empower themselves
obviously it's feminism but by sort of removing
their feminine traits which is so odd to me right
so it's like less so i'm not saying that i'm not
saying like feminism is i'm not saying like being
a woman is defined by how long your hair is and
like what you wear and all this stuff of course it
goes much deeper than that but you'll have to find
that people who are sort of promoting feminism are
sort of like um rejecting traditional feminine
values which is really odd to me it's sort of
like a contradiction you know yeah it's it's
really interesting it's it's like you know to be
better black people we're gonna stop being black i
mean like that would be is that that sounds weird
and silly but i i don't think ever every the
history is just a series of over corrections
um and when you look at it that way then every
everything makes sense because because look
as much as some people want to like rag on the
feminist movement you have to understand it it
sprung up because well at one point you know
women were getting getting left high and dry
by guys but when the law only you know you didn't
you should i got the right to vote for boy in the
united states before you got the right to vote you
know blacks before and we and we didn't think we
were treated like nothing so at some point uh you
just got to look at like how did all of this start
and then you go okay and this you know then you
go all right well we see how this happened and
see how this happened we can't really fix the
pass let's just kind of start all over and wipe
the slate clean i don't i don't know if that'll
ever happen that's that's like forgiveness on a
on a massive scale that humanity desperately needs
but we'll and i'm incapable of likely never get
there and i'm a huge proponent of forgiveness
so my mind immediately went well you know
you're never gonna really be able to balance
this out you just gotta wipe this clean and
and move forward but we'll see you know uh
people give me hope not so much recently but
but but in general man adaptability is the
name of our species or our ours as a trait
of our species so hopefully i think forgiveness
yeah i think forgiveness is huge i think that's
such a big point that you mentioned and i think
that's probably actually one of like the biggest
issues in society everybody's so angry at everyone
right like everyone is a minority in some place in
the world um you know whether it's your i don't
know whether it's like you're black you're white
you're jewish you're fat you're short your ginger
you're whatever the hell you are you know you're
asian you know somebody's not gonna like you um
i just think everyone's so angry like constantly
so important they're they're angry and even worse
they're angry about things they can't do anything
about and when i say they can't do anything
about it i i don't mean like they they can't
lobby and change laws or you know protest whatever
i mean they're we're angry about things that are
in the past and we look for reasons to be angry
and we're looking for reasons to be angry that we
we cannot do a thing about a big example this
played out on a huge stage across the world
was the decision to start tearing down statues
and i'm like okay well what's the end game here
and like you know what's your reason
well they did x y z and i'm like okay
if we start applying that principle that you can
never be anything or have any positive effect
or ever get any type of praise for anything you
did because you have something bad in your past
then no one is ever going to be in a position to
encourage or inspire anyone because people aren't
perfect and so we're at this position where this
point history where we can't we where you can't
you you can find a way you can finally get
you you dig hard enough and you can find
a reason to cancel anybody right and all canceling
is all canceling is an attempt to change the past
you did something awful or rather to make you
pay for for a transgression that perhaps wasn't
a transgression but now we've decided it is which
is even worse you know at least if you took my
money i can say okay i can see how much you took
i'm gonna take that back and some interest but if
you just decided it was a bad thing and it wasn't
at the time you know that's that's that's awful
we can't do that and all it does is just create an
endless cycle of anger because you're always going
to be able to look back and always move that goal
post you're always going to be able to go okay
i don't feel x y or z is good so i'm gonna see
how many people i can get to be angry about it
and it may be nothing here in the u.s i don't
know how they did it over there uh here in the us
a few years ago they decided we could no longer
play baby is cold outside on the radio right oh
really wait maybe i had that okay okay and and
i don't remember the reason but what i know
is that that song's been played for a
long time and now it's a big deal okay
it's crazy to me right and and we we decide it's
a big deal but then at the same time we decide
newer things that if you if you if you weigh them
on the same block of morality or affect people
you go okay that's crazy someone someone made it
made a great post and i thought it was hilarious
and then i i share things to stir
the bear or poke the bears and some
and he goes you know how woke do you have to be to
be offended by baby it's cold outside but not whop
that that song yes exactly exactly yeah i'm
done and i was like that's good i'm good
it's good i get it well but but the the point
is you know until you can let go of things
and we we have a big problem collectively
humanity i think is taking a backwards step
emotionally we we're not able to to let go of
stuff we want and and you know you can't let
go of it when you feel like there's something
you should get for a thing that was passed and
and since you can't extract resources you're
trying to deprive resources when you can't extract
uh when you can't actually change the past
you're trying to change everyone feels
in the present towards it they're actually like
physically altering things right now thinking
that that will make a difference like that changes
our history so i think yeah i think you make an
insane point right um that it's like how offended
how worked you have to be to be um offended by a
christmas song um but not offended by yeah what
or however you say like if you think about you
know do you know what i was listening to an ariana
grande song actually um in the gym the other day
and there's a line right and it and literally the
line is i won't actually fully say it because i
think like youtube might do something i don't
know but it just f me until the daylight is
the line okay so it's f me until until it's
daylight right and i'm like i'm like hold up
i was like when did this happen because i saw when
i was younger so i i'm 24 but when i was like 10
years ago when i was 14 or 12 whatever i remember
lady gaga had a song and the song was let me ride
on your disco stick right um only like 10 like 10
years later do i listen back and i'm like oh okay
i get what she's saying oh my god i can't believe
i was singing that next to my mom in the car
but eff me to the daylight it never used to be
like that and so how are we encouraging that
how are we encouraging little girls singing
that right and they will say it they will swear
but we're like but like oh my god
god forbid there's a christmas song
which is just you know not be correct and
that's not the only song i saw on bbc today
let me just get it um so bbc radio 1 will not
play original version of fairy tale of new york um
may be offended by derogatory terms for
gender and sexuality but we can definitely
play by ariana grande to 10 year old girls
effort until the daylights yeah it's a weird
it's a weird um ploy and a rare play and here's
another thing too because it's based on who did it
and not what they did that creates a huge problem
i'll i mean i'll never forget it was a great a
great post and i'm gonna paraphrase it uh because
i can't quite remember what i remember the idea
zooby made a post and he was talking about he made
it he was talking about uh you know saying the n
word and rap music and you got to understand like
like can white people say it or not because um
as there's a black person who's not american
you gotta understand that that's kind of
confusing to me like uh is is it a bad word
or is it only bad depends on who says it
oh okay my my thoughts on that you know i i
personally look okay so so first first and
foremost what people got to understand uh is
that the the n word used in music is not the
same thing that we were called in the 60s two
different words they're spelled differently uh
not not like so differently you're going to
confuse them you know but but they they're they're
pronounced differently they sound differently
they're not the same they're not used the same
whatever right so so that is the the first thing i
always make sure i'll bring up is that uh when you
look at language that's not the same word
there's not the same ideas not spelled
the same it's not used the same there's
nothing about those words that are same
as far as people getting offended
as if it were the same mhm that is
that's problematic that's problematic because
you're deciding that well and it's and it's not
problematic and because every every group has you
know their own terms you know that you use within
your own people or are terms that you you can
only like you know i i can call i i can call my
mom and ass but you know you do it you have
a problem you know that kind of thing right
the problem but that that's my
mom right now if i made a song
where i'm doing that and all of a sudden people
start coming up and going oh what's up man
is that your mom that the a-hole in the song okay
now we have a problem and and so so so now i've
got to make a decision as is as a gatekeeper of
that's that phrase i gotta go okay is it cool
or is it not cool and whatever i do has got to be
consistent across the board because there's going
to be a lot of people who have moms just like mine
they're going to hear and they're going to go yeah
mom you're like that mom you're in a hole too
they're like what's wrong with you like no that's
cool and said it about his mom so i was saying
about my mom they're totally different families
you know just because you're both moms and and
the point of my hand this this was not this this
totally ended up being uh a better knowledge
you know i thought it was when it came out
but the whole idea the whole point here is that
when you decide that whether the term is used
amongst black americans until you go and realize
that there aren't just black people in america
and those black people don't have the same
history so it's a hard way to differentiate it
and decide who can say what like when i was living
in portugal man i was amazed the radio was just
playing this music and it was like there's no
sensors nothing uh which over here you know
what used to be sensors now i was listening to
the radio of the day and i was like let's see
if they say what they what they used to censor
uh i don't remember the song but i was listening
intently and they didn't censor it i was like oh
okay it's new uh i but i guess i guess my point is
uh as much as i wanted to be a person my personal
issue the people won't let it be because how can
they either they're there there are enough
black people in the world and enough from
rightfully so that's the other thing rightfully
so uh can't get offended if it's used i just
think i think if you're gonna if you're gonna
make it a big deal personally you got to go
you can't use it and you no one can use
it if you use it army won't have a problem
i've met some older black men who are just like
that they're like don't use that word around me
i'm like okay that's cool because he's holding
the host holding all of us with standard
my issue is when you have guys that say all right
it's cool for me it's not cool for you that's um
that's going to create their own problems
i mean and they're going to be mad when
when someone shows up you know from from
freaking would say from from colombia
and they don't they don't know you know
i was in the dominican republic and
and all the people were shouting out to one
another at the resort hey uh blackie that's
what they call one of them really oh that sounds
awful it's not terrible sounds awful but it's just
the nickname blackie yeah you couldn't do it back
here but imagine export out the us knew that you'd
have an issue so so now now i think that genie's
out the bottle you know it's not going back in
i i but i can't tell people to live with it if
the rapper is stuck i'll tell you what here's
what happened if the rapper stopped using in
songs i i give it three years before for the
turn but they're not gonna stop using it in songs
because it's profitable people want to hear it so
um yeah i i tend to agree with everything you said
um i think the biggest okay so i think there's two
parts to it isn't it i think it's sort of like
taking ownership of a word which meant one thing
and being able to sort of be like no now this is
ours it's you know taking ownership of that but i
think at the same time i think this was maybe two
years ago i don't remember there was there was a
black rapper i can't remember who it was but he
had the n-word in a song and he was singing live
or whatever and he got a white woman to come up on
stage with him and um sing the the rap words and
it just so and then so she drops the n-word but
it was in the song so it caused a lot of issues
yeah everyone shouldn't
have said it well like okay
maybe she shouldn't have done but like but
this it's not clear where do we draw the line
like is it even possible to have a line lines are
inherently blurry so can we not just say like no
for everyone and then like move forward and then
people are going to be like hey and here's what
happened if you say no for everyone thinking like
how you gonna tell me i can't say it i'm one of
it's a hard one to discuss and and there is
probably never going to be a right answer
um all you got to do is make sure that
you you're in the that you don't use it
when you're in the right company uh a wrong
company i guess right it's not your audience
there you go know your audience because yeah i'm
with you i'm with you we've come to an hour which
is actually the longest i've done a podcast
for so that's super cool so we've oh really
no it's great no no it's fab it's great i love
it i usually go between like a half an hour to an
hour so i usually end at like 45 minutes 40 maybe
50 minutes but this is great do you have any final
words do you want you want to say oh this this has
been a a very fun conversation i had no idea what
was gonna go and i can tell you i have not talked
about about three of these topics on podcasts ever
no one's ever asked me about uh the masculinity
thing i thought that was cool uh this whole war
discussion that that was pretty uh entertaining
and then kind of the direction of of society
uh is very cool this this has been very fun
and i'm happy that you let me come on and we
could have a chat in front of your audience
yeah absolutely it's so good to have you so
i want to thank you so much for coming on
i want to um thank my um sponsors icon plus
blog fight coin flip and i also really want
to thank zelipe because i absolutely forgot
to thank them um and that that's a big mistake
for me so i'll uh i'll play that sponsorship
in a minute ed thank you so much and guys don't
forget to tune in next week thursday 12 est bye